Meine Botschaft ist, dass wir Sie beobachten werden
[Applaus]
Das ist alles falsch Ich sollte nicht hier oben sein
Ich sollte wieder in der Schule auf der anderen
Seite des Ozeans sein, aber Sie alle kommen zu uns
jungen Leuten, um Hoffnung zu bekommen, wie können Sie es wagen?  mit deinen leeren worten hast du
mir in meiner kindheit meine träume gestohlen
doch ich bin einer der
glücklichen menschen leiden
menschen sterben
ganze ökosysteme brechen zusammen wir
stehen am anfang eines massensterbens
und alles worüber du reden kannst ist geld
und märchen  des ewigen
Wirtschaftswachstums wie können Sie es wagen
[Applaus]
seit mehr als 30 Jahren die Wissenschaft
hilft kristallklar wie können Sie es wagen,
weiterhin wegzuschauen und hierher zu kommen und zu
sagen, dass Sie genug tun, wenn
die Politik und die erforderlichen Lösungen immer
noch nicht in Sicht sind, sagen Sie  Sie hören
uns und dass Sie die Dringlichkeit verstehen,
aber egal wie traurig und wütend ich bin, ich
möchte das nicht glauben, denn wenn
Sie die Situation wirklich verstehen und
weiterhin nicht handeln
würden, wären Sie böse und das lehne ich ab
Glauben Sie, dass die populäre Idee, unsere
Emissionen in 10 Jahren zu halbieren,
uns nur eine 50-prozentige Chance gibt, unter 1,5
Grad zu bleiben, und dass das Risiko
irreversibler Kettenreaktionen, die sich der
menschlichen Kontrolle entziehen, 50 % für Sie akzeptabel ist
, aber diese Zahlen beinhalten nicht
kipppunkte die meisten rückkopplungsschleifen
zusätzliche erwärmung versteckt durch giftige
luftverschmutzung oder die aspekte von gerechtigkeit und
klimagerechtigkeit sie verlassen sich auch darauf, dass meine
generation hunderte
milliarden tonnen ihres co2 aus der luft saugt mit
technologien die kaum existieren also ein 50%
risiko ist  Für uns,
die wir mit den Konsequenzen leben müssen, ist es einfach nicht akzeptabel,
eine 67-prozentige Chance zu haben,
unter einem globalen Temperaturanstieg von 1,5 Grad zu
bleiben  heute ist diese Zahl bereits
auf weniger als 350 Gigatonnen gesunken. Wie können Sie es wagen, so zu
tun, als könne dies mit dem
normalen Geschäft und einigen technischen
Lösungen
mit den heutigen verkauft werden?  ausstoß, dass die
verbleibenden co2-budgets in weniger als achteinhalb jahren vollständig aufgebraucht sein werden,
es werden hier heute keine lösungen oder
pläne präsentiert, die diesen
zahlen entsprechen, weil diese
zahlen zu unbequem sind und sie noch
nicht reif genug sind, es zu sagen  wie es ist
, enttäuschen Sie uns, aber die jungen
Leute fangen an, Ihren Verrat zu verstehen,
die Augen aller zukünftigen Generationen sind
auf Sie gerichtet, und wenn Sie sich entschließen, uns zu enttäuschen,
sage ich, wir werden Ihnen niemals vergeben
[Applaus],
wir werden Sie nicht davonkommen lassen  Damit
ziehen wir genau hier jetzt
die Grenze, die Welt erwacht und
Veränderungen kommen, ob es Ihnen gefällt oder
nicht, danke
[Applaus]